the Polish Grom is a tier 1 premier
special forces unit the operators of
this unit have gained the nickname the
surgeons due to their extensive medical
knowledge and training along with their
surgical like ability to coordinate and
execute special operations originally
grown was modeled from a number of NATO
Special Forces units including the u.s.
Delta Force the Navy SEALs Team six and
the British SAS looking back to the
1970s and 80s there were several
formations of special units within
Poland but these were either trained
purely an anti-terrorist operations or
military assignments such as espionage
and interfering with enemy
communications in 1989 a general
proposed that a Special Response Team be
established to counter the threat from
terrorism and other unconventional
dangers after the Polish Embassy in Bern
Switzerland was taken over by terrorists
Grom stands for something that I
probably shouldn't even have tipped to
pronounce basically it translates to
group for operational manoeuvring
response and is one of the five Special
Operations units of the Polish Armed
Forces the unit was named after the
silent unseen Poland's elite will work
to special operations unit candidates
applying to serve and Grom had to pass
psychological and durability tests along
with the so called truth test a
physically and psychologically
exhausting field test designed to filter
out the weaker applicants grom soldiers
trained with the best Special Operations
units in the world it was officially
activated on July 13th 1990 proximately
75% of Grom personnel are trained as
medics or paramedics in addition each
group is supported by several
professional physicians with the
reactivation of team rainbow in 2015 to
drum operators were recruited to assist
in the war on terrorism on a global
scale these operators was ophea and Ella
[Music]
you
I decide when to restrain
and want to kill
only the best call the shots
Sophia Bocek is an attacking operator in
team rainbow she is the eldest daughter
of a forward Grom commander and during
her childhood she lived comfortably in
Brawl swath poland when she was ten
years old her father resigned from his
role in the Grom in order to become the
minister of internal affairs following
the assassination of poland's president
from a very young age
Sofia underwent strict military training
read by a father as he has high hopes
and her fulfilling his legacy at times
she had a natural desire and wanted to
rebel against her father and choose her
own path yet she found immense comfort
in his simple black-and-white philosophy
and saw the benefits to a systematic way
of life Sophia's desire to become a
grunt specialist first arose while
attending a funeral the Polish president
looking across the room she was in all
of these individuals they seemed to
radiate a sense of presence and prestige
among all others her lifelong ambition
eventually became a reality
when she qualified to join Grom in order
to fully understand Sophia and her
psyche it's important to look at the
impact others have played on our own
personal growth and how she chose to
deal with it
on a school trip to the Missourian lake
district Sofia was the victim of
disturbing prank that almost cost her
life while swimming alone in the lake a
group of three boys from a class came
upon her and proceeded to take turns
trying to drown her just for fun in
relation to this violent and
life-threatening experience she
developed a marked and deep mistrust of
others with his terrifying event
unbeknownst to her teachers or any other
adults she then had to continue to sit
beside those same boys in class
thereafter feeling helpless and afraid
to deal with their increasing anxiety
she decided to push her training even
further than before to ensure that she
could protect herself in the future her
father readily agreed to show her more
ruthless techniques given only as long
as she continued to never questioned his
methods the next morning he leaves her
fear to the shooting range where he had
to stray dog leashed to a target post he
explained to her that decision will
determine the rest of your life and that
any true leader has to learn to make the
hard ones quickly one of the two dogs
was sick and Sophia must endure
suffering but which one he was forcing
her to make a quick calculated decision
based on very little information
it wasn't about teaching her right from
wrong it was about the skill she needed
to learn in order to survive Sophia's
eyes locked on to a chosen target and
she pulled the trigger with the firing
of her gun a heavy weight seemed to lift
off the chest and she caught a glimpse
of how strong in the future she would
become among Sophia's most notable
exploits with Grom was a rescue
operation in Guatemala Koch never buried
Agatha a tropical storm have formed a
sinkhole in the middle of the city
swallowing an entire neighborhood and
Sophia was deployed to protect the team
of engineers examining the perimeter
on this particular day she'd been
carrying out her duties abnormal when
suddenly of the line beneath her began
to collapse looking rapidly around she
noticed a young child alone with fear in
her eyes without a second thought
Sophia threw her on her back as the
youngster clung desperately to her
shoulders the earth fell out beneath her
feet
throwing herself at the edge of the
unbroken ground she managed to claw at
the ledge with her bare hands and for
the next half hour she clung to the
precipice over time Sophia managed to
forge a number of friendships oil
overseas and eventually some of those
people became like a second family too
far away from her father's brutal
training and with the loyalty and
kindness of others she began to lay down
a waltz and trust her teammates it was
in the midst of a rope mission in Mali
as she meet her now husband during an
operation where the both mistook each
other for hostiles
not long after their first encounter
they became engaged and decided on a
small wedding ceremony back in Poland
but her father who assumed she was
naturally involved in the organizing of
his daughter's wedding
chose to ignore her wishes and it's tip
opted for a large lavish event among the
invitees were a number of powerful
politicians who had seized control
around the time of the previous Polish
prisons death amid the congressmen she
noticed two former suspects in the
ex-presidents assassination and two had
discussed her father warmly embraced
them
Sophia had seen enough and she quickly
left the party with her husband the
actions that he Witte played heavily on
in mind she began to investigate further
what she'd seen and why a father could
allow himself to be caught up with such
allies though her inquest was put on
hold
not long after she began as she
discovered she was pregnant and decided
to take Billie maternity leave while
their husband remained working she moved
back home with her father and kept her
pregnancy hidden sadly before she was
able to inform them he died under
suspicious circumstances
motherhood had a profound effect on
Sophia and almost immediately after her
daughter was born the need to bring her
sister Ella closer was ignited she felt
the pull of responsibility and yearned
to keep her loved ones safe but Eller
ignored her attempts to reconnect after
hearing a sister had passed the
selection for grom as a civilian Sophia
returned back to work his squadron
noticed this change and witnessed the
efforts you made with her sister they
pondered amongst themselves
if this recent disposition was a remnant
of grief or something more when L
accepted the prestigious offer to join
team rainbow so fierce or no reason to
stay behind everything about Grom
reminded so fear of her father she used
a context to reach six personally who
agreed to meet her in Geneva and Sofia
join team rainbow three months later in
the younger days on the rear occasion
that Sophia was home alone with her
sister she will teach Ella a number of
advanced non-lethal techniques and
introduced her to concussion grenades
these secret lessons between them were
away for Sophia to reach out to her
sister who was markedly struggling
during high school
while her father's training meets a fear
most comfortable with hand-to-hand
combat and precision shooting she
discovered in the Brawn the kind of
specialist she wanted to be favoring
aggressive strikes she volunteered to
chase the trial ks7 nine lifeline a
double-barrel grenade launcher
originating from an Italian R&D program
the ks7 nine lifeline makes use of
electronically triggered projectile
technology that can fire both concussion
and impact ammunition since multiple
grenades are superposed in the gun
barrel reloading magazines is no longer
necessary resulting in unmatched
efficiency the concussion ammunition
delivers 170 decibel shockwave that
impairs hearing and causes a dizzying
effect the impact ammunition bulldozes
walls in an instant
it's a brutal dangerous world out there
but I found my way chaos is my home and
I'll make sure you never escape me this
viata Bocek is a defending operator in
team rainbow nicknamed Ella as highly
driven 30 year old is had a unique
progression having quickly risen among
Poland Special Forces she was deployed
in six countries an active in Iraq for
seven years her accomplishments come as
no surprise considering that she's the
youngest daughter of a former commander
of Poland's counterterrorism unit grom
but despite this legacy eller is not the
classic soldier you'd expect
originally from Ross suave Ella's family
history has deep roots within the city
her grandfather was an elite paratrooper
of the exiled Polish Army during World
War two after being captured during the
throt suave uprising he managed to
escape only to enjoy a three-month long
siege through his tales of war he
cultivated her defiant spirit and taught
a how much higher damage is done by
striking a supply chain and by
neutralizing a man
these invaluable lessons made her an
exceedingly smart and productive counter
AED operator
however she initially struggled with a
strict military lifestyle as a teenager
Ella experienced a number of
difficulties while attending military
high school because she was the daughter
of a former Grom commander
her records mention an undisclosed
incident six months before her
graduation which lead to expulsion from
here she had a brief stint inand other
Academy before a lack of attendance
caused her to be transferred again this
time to a small local high school which
she eventually graduated shortly after
her graduation l-lift pollen and
traveled to Berlin as she believed it
was time to experience life on her own
terms well there she studied the fine
arts although soon the appeal of her old
life began to creep up on it when Ella
made an acquaintance with the owner of a
small private military company over time
she was eventually offered a job craving
adventure along with financial
independence she accepted and hoped that
her role as a contractor would differ
from the stringent lifestyle that she
experienced with a military academy
during her first years of deployment in
Iraq if you gained quite the reputation
in the field no one to possess an
impressive range of abilities her
attitude was the only obstacle standing
in her way while she was seen as a
valuable asset to any squad her
employers monitored closely because of a
number of reports regarding her
authority issues sadly after a rough
operation in Baghdad she received the
news that her father had taken his own
life
some months after her father's death
Ella decided to terminate a contract and
began training and relentlessly in order
to pass the Grom selection as a civilian
in her rose
joining her late father's unit was her
way of keeping his memory close and make
amends for her past
thoroughly impressed by a determination
and aptitude in the field the Polish
forces took her on and among the Grom
she developed an expertise in countering
threat networks and helped design
advanced methods to extract Intel on a
targets objectives and supply routes one
of her most notable ventures is
operation orange sky we're joined by
Valkyrie
seals Intel expert elephant months and
full trading of warlords in a circle
before dismantling his network without
harming a single civilian her
partnership with seal proved so
effective that she was tracked down by
team rainbow inspired by the 1939 anti
tank polish grenades used for the iconic
silent unseen paratroopers during world
war ii the sticky mines could be
anchored on surfaces impairing hearing
and causing a dizzying affect these
concussion mines are triggered a prompt
proximity affecting anyone within its
radius this non-lethal explosive was
specifically adapted to Ella who is
known to isolate targets from the local
population to sabotage AED operations
hey guys thank you very much for all of
the suggestions over which ones I should
be covering next unfortunately there are
a number that don't have too much story
behind them it may be that this hasn't
been released yet when the others were
done or they may never be updated I'll
keep an eye on them for now and see if
they change anyway if you've made it
this far thank you very much for
watching and I'll catch you in the next
one Cheers